[Musique]
tu es un monstre
monstre
[Applaudissements]
mon cher ami je serais très en colère contre
toi si tu mourais
j'ai besoin de quelque chose pour mourir pour des
os droits et pleurer
et je n'aurai pas honte de
mon seul but sur cette terre  est d'aimer
roxanne sait-elle que le monde
n'acceptera jamais quelqu'un comme moi et une grande
belle femme nous n'avons pas d'argent un
mariage intelligent est votre seule option je
ne serai pas sauvé je ne suis pas en détresse l'
amour est-ce que cela ne signifie rien pour vous
les enfants ont besoin d'amour les adultes ont besoin d'argent
j'ai une confession à me faire je suis
follement amoureux peut être qu'il ressent la même chose
mais je ne lui ai jamais vraiment parlé de
ton amour je pense
qu'il est chrétien
chrétien savait
qu'il était une nouvelle recrue dans ton régiment  sois
son ami je pourrais ne pas l'aimer
une femme comme roxanne veut du poids je
ne sais pas parler de façon romantique je
suis un poète mes mots sur tes lèvres je
te rendrai romantique pendant que tu me fais un
pantalon elle m'aime
pour que quelqu'un dise
mon  l'amour pour toi est si puissant mon amour
pour toi est si puissant qu'il h  comme la
force d'hercule il a la force
d'
hercule hercule
parle moi comme tu le fais dans tes lettres
tu es une belle fleur je ne suis pas une
fleur j'ai besoin de plus
tu es amoureux d'elle
mon destin est de l'aimer de loin
nous  doit la laisser décider de notre destin
elle doit avoir le choix
[Musique]
toi